babbels joker und herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem neuen video
[Musik]
hier seht es bereitete eingeblendet max
und ich machen heute einen quilt youtube
kurs wir wollen uns gedacht denkt könnte
sich einfach mal 76 39 20 vielleicht
auch liefert sie einfach eine menge
fragen ausgesucht über verschiedene
youtuber über irgendwelche instagram
bild aber keine ahnung was wasser zeit
abgeben und max und ich müssen diese
fragen beantworten und am ende weniger
fragen richtig beantwortet hat wird mit
nerd ganz abgeschlossen
willkommen zum quiz die frage 1 richtig
wäre in der letzten woche hat tanzverbot
ein rap video hochgeladen in dem er
seine eigentlichen sprache heraus wie
viele reale wörter hat er trotzdem in
diesem lied direkt antwort a
antwort b nein antwort c 16 und antwort
d 21 jahre alt ich wollte mich war das
der farbe aufgebracht
also ich hab so mitbekommen das ist
schon gewarnt
tatsächlich hat keiner die richtige
anlage war der erste ard 21 wörter was
ich gesagt wie sagst du bitte von
montana black kümmert sich selber wenig
zum stream highlights die auf youtube
upload werden er hat dafür zwei kanäle
die das für ihn übernehmen
viele klicks haben diese beiden kanäle
die crew und richtiger kevin zu
statisten
antwort a 7 millionen rand rund 27
millionen antwort c 16 millionen oder
antwort d 19 5 mio
ich kann glaube ich ganz grob
einschätzen ich nicht weiß 21 tc
tatsächlich richtig sein kann erinnerung
zusammen 19 15 uhr will er gesagt 19,5
damit bedenken ja okay das müsste
richtig weit weniger com 21 04 mag der
eine oder andere mitbekommen hat ist
billig beauty palace schwanger sie hat
einen fan geschenkt per post bekommen
was hat sie dazu geschickt bekommen eine
komplette baby wohnanlage
b das erste kuscheltier des fans für ihr
kind zu klamotten fürs baby im stil von
blumen oder de ein selbst gebautes
kinderspielzeug die ja all das könnte
alles möglich sein teilen schimmern ich
musste jetzt was ich raten würde ich
nicht überhaupt keine ahnung
ja ich glaube ich ich rate einfach
wieder frei
21 d ist tatsächlich leider falsch ein
fan hat sein erstes kuscheltieren dass
er jahrelang hatte ein baby geschickt
und mir hat es aber zurückgefahren kann
man das verstehen aber schon aber ich
wollte grafen geste von dem verein gebe
wie viele abonnenten konnte helmut zeit
anfang 2018 seit dem ersten erster
zugewinn antwort a 820.000 abonnenten
antwort b 650.000 abonnenten antworten
c900 10.000 abonnenten oder andere de
530.000 alter ich schwanke zwischen 221
b tatsächlich ist es aber von 820.000
abonnenten merkte der erst 80.000 anfang
des jahres wunsch auf wie vielen vom
release 6 letzten instagram bildern ist
er alleine zu sehen
antwort a
auf keinem antwort b antwort c auf 3
oder antwort d auf ballen also dass er
alleine die einzige person auf dem bild
ist deshalb traten bei mir bei 21 de ich
glaube wirklich die beides leider fall
nein einem bild alleine ich dachte
nämlich gerade dass er vielleicht auf
jedem bild einfach drauf das war ja so
die weiter
wir machen jetzt das letzte frage was
ist wenn ich keine frage was hat ihnen
damit war der in seinem garten aufgebaut
leute die erste folge des youtube chris
cris youtube geht an den kran luca 32
anders wäre das heutige wieder
allerdings auch wenn meine damen und
herren sind euch getan hat das gerne
behalten in die kommissare was nächstes
mal die bestrafung sein sonst entsteht
ist schreibt er in die kommentare was in
einer woche bei teil 2 von diesem
youtube kurs für eine bestrafung machen
sollen ihr könnt doch fragen die
kommentare schreiben
sie stellt sich die anschauen und sonst
[Musik]